Hi, I'm Guillermo Arduino
And this is Pew News
Welcome to the channel, sorry about the screaming man.
I hope you have a nice time reading my subtitles, you should find me in the comment section somewhere.
Oh, look at that! The video is longer than 10 minutes this time!
Welcome to Pew News!
The most legitimate news source on the entire internet
You might as well put this news iiiiiin
the dictionary because it's SO. LEGIT.
just spit 'da truth'
On da 'Poo News'.
The first story comes from.... 'Bloomberg' ... (???)
A wOnDeRfUlLy wRiTtEn ArTiClE about displayed YouTube (the almighty) and as always
in the most "accurate" way possibe!
The title reads as follows: Success on YouTube
still means a life of poverty. (yeah totally)
"Wow! I'd best be clickin' on this!" I'm joking of course
this is clickbait but nonono it's not, aight? (I don't even know anymore)
A vlogger in the top 3 percent might
get more than 1.4 million views a month (more than you, pewds?)
Dayum!
Das LOW! (O shit burrnnnnn)
I think when I quit youtube to do full time
Euhhhhhhhh I had about 17 million views a month
But arguably, things are different now,,, there's-
There's more ways to monetize your content,
There's Patreon (get him that Lamborghini) there's donations, there's uhhhhhh
sponsorships, there's... All these kinds of
things that matter more these days than just
your average-- how many views do you get per month.
The article reads as follows:
"Do your children dream of YouTube stardom? Do them a favour:
CRUSH THAT AMBITION NOW."
*giggle giggle* to be honest, I 100% agree.
But also, at the same time,
look at any other entertainment industry. What is really your
top chances of breaking into that? Isn't it really
a dream?? An unacheivable goal??? o.0
It certainly was for when I started YouTube, I---it-----I
It seemed impossible. (back to the article) "In fact,
96.5% of all those trying to
become YouTubers won't make enough money off of advertising
to crack the U.S. poverty line,
According to research by Mathias Bärtl,"
What does the numbers mean?,,,
J̶a̶s̶o̶n Bärtl... Mathias,
Whatever your name is
*cackling a cold, hard cackle as if he'd just roasted someone so hard they fucking burnt to death*
You can't just take a percentage, and not tell us
what numbers you took that from! (that's plagarism!)
Did you take every single person that has a YouTube account?
Because then, yes! 3% might seem small,
But it's also massive! Did you pin it down to people that
have actually uploaded ONE video on the platform or
one per month, perhaps, or maybe one per year orrrrr
How consistent do we have to be to be part of the study?
Or maybe you didn't 'pin it down' at all
and you just literally took every single person on
the website, regardless of whether they upload videos or not
We don't know! So the 3% ... I'm sorry,
It doesn't matter! The study is useless!
You've basically proven nothing. Unless you
tell us where you got the numbers from!
Despite YouTube lately being
like a black hole ;) getting sucked in on
itself lately... it is still
one of the best, if not the best place to monetize your content
When vine went down (RIP in piece) all the vine stars
went to YouTube (ask the Cheese of Truth for more details)
Or at least the ones that managed to get successful did.
I'm talking about you, Piques... hehehe
hELl nO !!1!!!11!!
Viners went to youtube because
YouTube is one of the best places to monetize your content
You have people literally own social networks
where they don't get any ad revenue,
like Instagram (@tragic_triggers),,, you just exclude their income completely
from having sponsorships.
Bloomberg? *mmm pop*
It is mentioned, I think, briefly somewhere I don't see it.
They also calculate here they-tha-theee
income of $1
for every thousand views, which is pretty terrible even for
my low revenue standards. (Haha yeah sure, Pewds.)
Even I got a little shoutout in this video! Thank you, Buttsburg! tHaNk yOu!
(back to article) Gaming YouTubers - such as 28-year-old
Felix "Papa-Pewds" Kjelberg,
who has 60 million subscribers - have a
14 times better chance than traditional vloggers
who often upload to the People & Vlogs
category on YouTube"
That's right everybody, my channel is filled with gaming content!
As proved here by Bloomberg!
Check out my gaming videos guys I think you'll really enjoy them
I think it's interesting how the media
has presented this idea that YouTubers earn so much money
Any time I'm discussing with the media, every single
time I get the question, " Hey Felix, so how much
money do you make?" and I always say
"Well, that's none of your business, but it's a damn lot."
I'm joking.
I think it is an interesting conversation now,
speaking about last episode
when we discussed how Fiverr
there's no real job guarantee and safety-net
for working through these websites.
Yes, YouTube is an amazing platform for you to monetize your content and create your own business,
but it's not like a traditional job
And it probably shouldn't even be looked at in that sense.
Yes, you don't get healthcare
Yes, you have to work insane hours and you make up your own time
And uhh, yes you don't have any form of job safety and it's really all up to you.
But it's also... a great oppourtunity.
"And you were also involved in the YouTube demotisation wave
after that 'poodeepie' cocksucker
decided it was a good idea to use the n-word (O yeah that did happen...)
Oh video game streams"
Joe Rogan! Please, Joe, please!
*another psychotic giggle, please get him to a mental asylum before he kills Brad and Brad #2*
I may be a cocksucker, Joe. You got me there ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
But I didn't create the adpocolypse
This is a common misconception that happens all the time
and I thought, why not take--
take a moment now, and explain to everyone
why I didn't create the adpocalypse.
(In the 16th century, blasphemy was a worse crime than murder. Look it up.)
I understand that it's easy to project your
feelings of anger into ideas that
are not consistent with reality.
I'll take the punch. I get it. Whatever makes you feel better.
Whatever makes you sleep at night.
But I keep seeing it so let's discuss it.
"DiSnEy sErVeRs TiEs WiTh yOuTuBe sTaR pEwDiEpIe aFtEr AnTi-SeMeTiC-"
FUNNY VIDEOS!
Just kidding.
I lost a show, that I worked on that nearly killed me *snickers* (get some nuts)
I've never been more depressed in my life while shooting that
And I lost, uhh, 'Google Prefered' (TF is that) which I honestly had no idea I was even in to begin with
So it wasn't like
"Aww damn"
If anything the whole situation sucked for everyone else around me that got dragged into this
That weren't really highlighted.
People associate this article to somehow creating the adpocalypse,
or at least being part of the next stepping stone.
When OHNONO, it's not true! Let's look at the facts here, guys.
Only the facts on Poo News, thank you.
It was the-- what was it?
London Times? Back in 'March 17'
posted:
"YouTube hate preachers share screens with household names"
And they have this video with a bunch of hate preach
And it being displayed with advertising content
This inevitably lead to Wall Street Journal dipping their toes into the issue as well,
on March the 24th
"Google's YouTube Has Continued Showing Brands' Ads With Racist and Other Objectional Videos"
None of my videos were involved in any of these articles.
This was about extremist content, ISIS videos,
political hate preach, etc. etc.
Right after, same day,
"YouTube is facing a full-scale advertising boycott over hate speech"
Companies like PepsiCo, Walmart, Dish, Starbucks, and GM pulled out their advertising, joining a group of dozens of companies.
Starting with Europe, which then lead to America joining in as well with AT&T and Verizon pulling ads as well
This is what lead to a decrease of ads on YouTube for a brief period of time
And at the same time YouTube had to create with a new system
uh, to show advertisers that "yes, we are working on these issues to make sure that this doesn't happen again."
Now, ads showing up on content that it shouldn't belong at isn't a new thing.
It happens a lot of times, maybe ads show up on porn
Or ads showing up just anywhere where the advertiser probably wouldn't be happy to see.
(SPOILER:) Companies are companies!
They're not moral beings.
They pull out of this advertisement, not for the sake of being manipulated by the media, orr,,,
Having some sort of bigger moral idea about it
A lot of advertisers pulled out just so they could hurt Google in the process (Kinda like Brexit)
You have companies like Verizon which is one of the biggest spenders on advertisement online
which pulled out during this adpocalypse
And Verizon owns Yahoo (it's so dead though)
Of course these companies benefited from this move.
They can basically negotiate for better, uhh, pricing as well.
Along with TV networks
using this as an opportunity to hopefully pull more
ads back into TV which they have been losing out on for so long.
"Publishers that are using this for their agenda, you know there's advertisers like AT&T and Verizon,
All the telecom guys that have pulled out
You know, this is not just because 'oh, my ads got, you know,
are on bad content,' these people want a piece of this business"
-"Absolutely"
-"So everybody, you know,
has their motivation for going after Google on this, everyone wants the money"
-"Everybody wants a piece of that Google Pie"
It's pretty shortsighted to say that this whole thing happened because of some sort of moral cause,,,
Even though, yes it was a bad thing.
BUT!
It's even more shortsighted to put the blame on me for it.
Even though it might make you feel better.
I honestly wouldn't mind taking the blame for it,
I just don't think it is true..
And you might say "Well maybe, Pewds, you were part of the puzzle, you know?"
"It started off with you, and then all the media started criticising YouTube"
And I think 'yes! But how the heck is that my fault?"
Maybe if YouTube weren't so reactionary to all these issues,,,
NONE OF THIS WOULD'VE EVEN HAPPENED!
Or at least the effect would have been less...
YouTube is taking over all media:
"YouTube Tops 1 Billion Hours of Video a Day" (damn)
YouTube is taking the ads away from TV,
that TV dollar
It's only a matter of time, really, at this point.
But the real question is 'How is YouTube going to shape into what it becomes?' (3deep5you)
In the previous article we talked about the Boogersburg thing
They mention that it's even harder for smaller creators now because
you have to have at least 4 thousand hours your videos
Aaaand 1 thousand subscribers to get ads on your content.
It might seem like a punch in the gut for small creators,
but for everyone on the platform, it's a great thing
so hopefully, this whole fiasco doesn't happen again.
NOW ON THE NEXT NEWS!
I have my own merch! Have you checked it out yet?
Thank you..
You can go to represent.com/pewdiepie to get one of the
CAN YOU DO THIS??™ MERCH
That's right, you want some dead memes on your  ̶f̶a̶c̶e̶ on your shirt?
Of course you do!
What else are you going to wear?
In probably more exciting news, me and Marzia launched our own clothing brand
which is not merch
We wanted to do something of higher quality,,,
we wanted to make it as ethical as possible,,,
and well-designed.
Aeuhhh, all the items are custom-fitted which is a much higher price than what people are used to in the merch
We sold out our first line.
And we couldn't be happier with all the responses, it's been amazing!
You can still pre-order for the next 8 weeks,
for it to arrive, you can,,,
If you missed out, you can still order.
So please still do, because it helps us out a lot and support our dream of making this clothing brand!
(ﾉ◕ヮ◕)ﾉ*:･ﾟ✧
That was it for this week's Puke News!
My name is Guillermo -----
Fuck I forgot my name-